mind here that Zad al Maad is
written in a way that is very
different or somewhat different
than the other books that may
refer to these subjects. So,
he's written this book and it
has a cluster of all kinds of
things about the prophet So, it
issues
of issues of history and
issues of medicine, issue,
anything that has to do with
the prophet so he's written
this book in a way that the
companions would have
understood and seen and looked
at the prophet what do I mean
by that? The scholars of Fiq,
when they went to take worship,
take particular issues in order
to be able to understand and in
order for them to be able to
teach it in a way that is
definite, definitive, meaning
that, this is what makes this
is the bare minimum, this is
the extra, this is preferable.
So, they separate rated and
categorized different things
into different categories. We
have the conditions, we have
the pillars, we have
obligations, we have things
that are preferable, we have
things that invalidate, things
that are prohibited, things
that are disliked and
discouraged, etcetera. So, we
can make a list. How do we come
up with this? Well, we examine
the examined all of the
narrations all of the verses,
everything having to do with
that particular act of worship
and look for these patterns
that kind of make themselves
obvious and manifest themselves
in such in such a practice and
this is what is referred to as
a subble, a subtle in the
science of fif or is that an
individual takes all of the
verses, all of the narrations
that they have and They put
them all together and then
start to look for patterns The
companions
most of the time would not
differentiate in their actions
and in their ad herence would
not differentiate between
something obligatory and if the
prophet did it, we will do it.
Right? Yes, the of the
companions, the Mufteen, of the
Companions, Abu Huraira, Ibn
Abbas, Ibn Omar, Abdullah, Ibn
Omar, Ibn Omar, Abdullah, Ibn
Masroud, etcetera. They knew
these categorizations and they
alluded to them. However, when
they would hear something or
see something that the prophet
did, they would do it. When he
would not do something or
discourage it, they would leave
it alone.
So he authored his book in this
way. Very little do we find
that he differentiates between
that which is that which is
Mustahab. He just mentions. The
prophet used to pray this.
This is how he prayed. This is
what he did. We don't find that
categorization. Because again
the subject of the book and the
topic of the book is not the
fiq. necessarily a book of
filk in the traditional sense.
It's a book about the prophet
But in order for us to
understand these chapters
properly, we have to go through
this categorization in order to
be able to understand and
retain what it is we are
learning To make sure that
we're able to differentiate
between for instance, fasting,
a fast which is acceptable, a
fast which is preferable, a
fast which is invalid,
etcetera. In order for us to
know where we stand with
regards to these issues. So,
the scholars have all agreed
that fasting is obligatory upon
an individual that has six
conditions, six traits. The
first is that a person is
Muslim. What does that mean
Muslim? Does this mean that
Islam's obligations are only
obligatory upon Muslims? That
non Muslims are not obliged to
and compelled to follow the
Quran and Sunnah. Yes, of
course they are. All of is.
The prophet was sent to
everybody and everybody is
obliged to follow his command.
But what the scholars mean when
they say fasting is obligatory
upon Muslims. It doesn't mean
that non Muslims are not
obliged to fast. What it means
is that non Muslims are not
commanded to fast. At first the
first thing they're commanded
to do is accept the slim,
right? Then, we will tell them
about prayer. Then, we will
tell them about zakah. Then, we
will tell them about fasting.
We don't come to them and say,
well, at least fast. No. At
least pray. You have to.
Establish that, worship, on a
bedrock, and a foundation of
Muhammad or Rasulullah. So,
Allah Wa Salam. So, when we
say, it is obligatory upon
Muslims. What is meant is they
are commanded immediately to
fast. Whereas someone who is
not entered Islam is first
commanded to enter Islam,
right? The second is that a
person is sane and we discussed
what is meant by sanity in the
legislative sense. Al Which is
a person who is a pubescent
age. And we discussed what the
age of puberty is. We said the
latest is 15 years old. And
there are other traits that a
person may exhibit. That
articulate that a person has
reached the age of puberty and
we discuss that. The next is
someone who is healthy and not
ill and that's what we'll
discuss tonight inshallah. We
also discussed Al Mukim,
somebody who is a resident and
not a traveler and we mention
the opinion of Ibn ul Kaim, the
opinion of Sheikh Al Islam, the
way of the companions for the
most part in understanding
traveling, and that is that
traveling is when a person is
not a resident and when a
person is a he is not
traveling. So a person as long
as they are in a land that they
are not living and residing in.
They don't have a house, they
don't have, you know, they
don't live there. Then, the
individual is a traveler. A
person is passing through,
they're staying in a hotel,
they're staying in this person
is a traveler. A person goes
for Omrah. And they're staying
in a hotel. Are they a resident
there? No. They are a traveler.
And so the rulings travel,
apply to that, to them. If they
were to rent an apartment and
stay there if they were to, do
the things which would make a
person a resident, then now
they will have the ruling of a
person who is a resident. Say,
well, I lived there for a
while, right? Even if it's only
two or 3 months, then, I'm
living there but if a person is
passing through then, a person
is not considered to be a
resident. Therefore, they are a
traveler, right? What
constitutes travel? What
constitutes travel is that a
person have the intention of
traveling and leave the
boundaries of their city? That
is what traveling is. There's a
narration. And
I believe that
left Baghdad had left
his city, capital city in Iraq.
excuse me
[Silence]
and as they reach the outskirts
of the city right? As they
reach the outskirts of the
city, they passed by a a is a
hut. A hut. What we call in in
follow you know in Palestine
dialect is right? A little hut.
A small and he said
he said, when they reached this
part of the the the town, they
were on their way out and then
they stopped for salah and he
saw a small hut for one of the
people living on the outskirts
of the city and he said, had it
not been for this hut, we would
have, joined our prayers. What
does that mean? It means that
this hut is part of the city.
So, he didn't leave the city
yet until he passes that. This
is how A
who understood that? And so,
when is a person travelling?
Let's take a an example from
where we are here, right? Let's
say I want to travel. would I
join my prayers before I leave
my house? No. I can break my
fast before I leave my house.
That's a different topic.
Fasting and and prayer have two
different rulings in this
regard. But I would still make
my prayer on time and not join
the prayers and I would make
them in full. But let's say now
I get on the highway and I
leave the boundaries of Chicago
area right? Now, I'm traveling.
Once I leave those boundaries.
Now, I will shorten my prayers
and I will join my prayers.
Even if I'm only a few miles
out of the boundaries of my
city. That's not what's
important. What's important is
that I've left my city with the
intention of traveling and the
destination in mind is a
destination that would
constitute travel, right? Now,
I will shorten my prayers
regardless of the of the So,
some of the scholars and the
different they mention eighty
kilometers, 90 kilometers.
However, mentioning a
particular distance is for the
most part, not very precise.
Why? Because if a person is at
79 kilometers or at 78
kilometers, with a person at 80
kilometers, one kilometer ahead
of them, they can see them
right? On a clear date, that
person would shorten his
prayers and the person at 79
kilometers would pray in full?
No. Right? They're all
traveling. So, the point here
is that traveling is based on
the intention and leaving the
boundaries of, the boundaries
of the city, right? That is
traveling. The sixth and final
characteristic of a person who
needs to fast, applies only to
women, only to females, and
that is that they not be in a
state of menstruation or
postpartum. Postpartum
administration is all the same
ruling and all of except in
three issues and this is not
one of those three issues.
Right? So, postpartum and
menstruation, they go hand in
hand in all issues of except
for three issues. Fasting is
not one of them. So, if woman
is on menstruation or she's in
her cycle or having postpartum
which is after giving birth in
Nephas. Then, she is exempted
from fasting and she would make
up her fasting. So, this is
these are the tight, this is
the kind of person whom fasting
is obligatory upon. Right? So,
let's mention them. There's
six. Five for men and six for
females. Number one, a person
is Muslim. We mention what that
means Number two, that they are
sane. We discussed that. Number
three, that the person is, is
of pubescent age. Right? And we
said the latest, the person
will reach is 15 years old.
That's the absolute latest.
Number four, is that a person
is healthy? Number 5, that a
person is a resident. And
number six, which applies only
to females that there not be
any in a state of menstruation
or postpartum, right? Now What
is meant by a that a person is
is healthy. Does any of us have
100 percent health all the
time? No. Right? unless you're
a young man or unless you're
right, we're going to have
some, you know, the older you
get, the more you start to feel
that but the point is, is that
and you know, I'm not that old
but I've definitely felt it and
the point is is that person is
not at 100% health. What's
meant why health is that a
person is not affected by
fasting? That's what meant,
what's meant to my health here
in this context? Let's say I
have some kind of rash. Am I at
100% health? No. Am I healthy
to where fasting is obligatory?
Yes. Right? Because I need to
put some cream on this rash or
something that. It doesn't
affect my fast. If I fast or if
I don't fast, it will be the
same result with regards to
that particular ailment, right?
However, there's three
instances What's meant by
health is health with regards
to fasting. So, when the
scholars say, fasting is
obligatory upon those who are
of health. It means that your
fast will not affect that
particular issue, right? That's
what's meant. It's important
for us to understand that. Now,
The same thing would go for
Hajj for instance, right? Hajj
is obligatory upon a person who
is able. What does that mean?
That means your Hajj will not
will not affect your health.
You won't get more sick or not
become better or what have you.
This is what's meant by health.
So, each category has its
different categorization. So,
there's three instances in
which fasting would not be
obligatory. Now, notice the
wording I'm saying, obligatory,
binding, wedge. Meaning, if you
If you break your fast, then
you are being sinful. You're
not doing something that is
obligatory but it doesn't mean
that you can't fast, okay? Just
someone who is traveling.
It doesn't mean that they can't
fast. It just means it's not
wedge. If it's not obligatory,
okay? If a person has an
ailment, an illness, excuse me.
If a person has an ailment, an
illness, and if they fast, it
will either one make them more
ill. Number two, it will stop
them from healing. Or number
three, they have to take some
medicine that would break their
fast for this illness. This
person is not considered to be
of of health to where fasting
is obligatory. Right? So, three
three things. Number one, the
person will become more sick,
more ill by fasting. It will
hurt them. Number two, their
recovery will be delayed.
Because of fasting. Or number
three, they have to take some
kind of medicine or something.
Even if it's food. Right? That
makes a person break their
fast. and if they don't take
this thing, it will either make
them more sick or it will delay
their recovery. These three
things exempt a person from
having to fast. Let's talk
about the first one. Let's
review them real quick. I
want to make sure these things
are sticking. Number one, the
person
what's the first one? They
become more sick by fasting.
Number two,
come on guys. I know em. I want
you guys to know.
Their recovery will be delayed.
Number three. They're they have
to take something that would
break their fast this this this
would either delay their
recovery or make them more
sick, right? So, three things.
So, let's discuss the first
one. We said the first one was,
It will increase their illness.
What's that mean? Well,
let's say a person has
something like
of
a very well-known one like
diabetes
for instance, right? Okay,
diabetes is an an interesting
thing because So, certain days,
you might find that you're able
to fast and other days, it
[Silence]
will be harmful if you fast,
right?
[Silence]
Insulin, does insulin, insulin
shot? Does that break your
fast?
Huh?
No. Is insulin food?
Is
it food?
Does it nourish? No. Doesn't
break your fast. The only thing
that breaks your fast is
something that takes the place
of food.
What takes the place
of food? an IV, right? An
IV that you does vitamins or a
vaccine take the place of food?
Does nicotine patch take the
place of food? Does a
suppository take the place of
food A suppository is medicine
that's inserted via the rectum.
From this, we take that, yes,
smoking breaks your fast,
right? Because it goes into the
So, when we say you have to
take medicine, we're speaking
about medicine that would break
your fast, So, if a person has
something diabetes and
they're able
to
have Sahul and
not be affected
by their
fast
that particular day, then, they
and if they're unable to fast
that particular day, something
comes up where they need to
break their fast, they break
their fast, right? We have
number one, a person is hurt by
his fasting. If you are hurt,
if you fast and it will
physically hurt you, it will
hurt you in the, in the sense
of, it will make you
[Silence]
sick
Then it is haram for a person
to fast in this case.
Right?
If a person
were to
fast and it would be
detrimental to their health to
fast, then, it is haram for
them to fast, okay? Let's say
Number two, if a person has an
ailment and and illness or an
ailment, if they have an
illness and fasting delays
their recovery. Our brother
brought up an interesting one
which is the flu. That's
an interesting illness because
when a person has a fever, when
a person has all of these
symptoms of a flu, right? If
they fast, they could probably
make it through the day and
they won't be more sick.
However, it will delay their
recovery, correct? Because if
you have an fever, if you have
an illness the flu, you
treat the symptoms, you have to
drink water, you have to eat,
you have to do these things
too. Hasten your recovery. So,
if a person If they fast, it
will delay their recovery, then
they don't have to fast But is
it permissible for them to
fast? Yes. Is it better for
them to fast? Well, that
depends on the situation. And
depends on the severity of the
illness, etcetera. But in
general, it is better for them
to to not fast, and hasten
their recovery. Number three,
if they need something, the
fasting doesn affect their
health. It doesn't affect their
illness. It doesn't increase
their illness or delay their
recovery but what happens? They
have to take something for
another illness that's not
included and this thing
constitutes that they break
their fast. some kind of
pills that they have to take or
something of that sort. Then
they do not have to fast in
that case. they do not have to
fast in that case. Now,
So, as we're discussing these
things, it's right Ramadan is
right around the corner and
these things are going to come
into play very soon for all of
us. If anyone has anything that
they don't understand and
that's in general, in all the
classes that we always mention,
if you have a question or you
didn't understand what I have
mentioned, then, you should ask
immediately as we're going
through the class inshallah.
So, these are the this is the
criteria for a person to for a
for it to be obligatory upon a
person to fast. The same thing
goes with traveling. If a
person travels and fasts and
fasting makes them sick while
they're traveling, is it
permissible for them to fast?
No, it is not permissible.
The man, Cana, Mughman Alaihi,
Min, Harashemsi women, Anna,
[Silence]
intensity of the heat, none of
us was fasting on that day
except for the messenger of
Allah. And Abdullah, Ibn Rawaha
So,
we understand from this
that fasting is permissible
while you are traveling but it
is not obligatory. Even if a
person is fine, they don't find
any hardship in fasting.
Whatsoever. While they're
traveling, they still have the
the permissive permission to
break their fast. However, is
it better for them to fast or
better for them to break their
fast? If it is not harmful.
It's better for them to fast.
Why? Because fasting during
Ramadan with the rest of the
Muslims all together is
obviously better. Plus the time
is a virtuous time. Right? Now.
Now, fasting has two pillars.
We've mentioned now the
criteria upon whom does fasting
is fasting binding, obligatory?
We mention six traits, right?
Let's mention them. Number one,
Muslim, number two,
Well, let's not go in out of
order because we're going to
get confused. Number two,
number one, Muslim. Number two,
sane, sanity. Number three,
puberty. Number four, health.
Number 5, resident, and number
six, a person for females that
they're not in a state of
menstruation or postpartum and
we said, what's meant by health
is that fasting does not make
you more sick or delay your
recovery or number three. That
you have to take something that
would otherwise break your
fast, okay? So, we've mentioned
some things that common and we
will get into what will break
your fast in a in a few
inshallah. themselves. 9
minutes. Okay. I thought she
said it was nine o'clock.
Alright. I forgot my glasses. I
can't see anything. The pillars
of fasting.
Rokinani.
A And Yum Sika and Al Mufturat.
Men Ulu Al Fajari, Ila, Rayab
Shamsi
[Silence]
and they don't know if Ramadan
is tomorrow morning, right?
They didn't hear. They don't
know. And they didn't have an
intention to fast. And they
woke up at fajr. But they woke
up after the of fajr. Did they
have to make up that day? Yes.
Right? Okay? Let's say an
individual says, I'm not sure
if tomorrow is Ramadan, if
tomorrow is Ramadan, then I
plan to fast and then they wake
up at fajr. Is that going to be
valid? Yes. Then no The prophet
said, whoever has not made the
conscious intention to fast
before fajr, then their fast is
not, is not valid, is not
complete. The second thing that
will break a person's, the
second thing, the second pillar
of fasting is that an
individual refrain from the
things that break their fast.
From the break of dawn, from
until the sunset. Okay? Those
are the two pillars of fasting.
Easy. Salah has 14 pillars,
right? Fasting has two pillars.
Now, what are the things that
break a person's fast? You can
memorize them. They are six
things. Six things that will
break your fast. Anything
outside of these thick six
things that we are going to
mention will not. will not
break your fast, okay? So, you
will know based on these things
that your fast is valid or is
not valid. The first thing is
eating or drinking.
Bahada A
Al Qa Al Was saddest. Al Jimah.
[Silence]
break a person's fast. This
will break a person's fast and
that issue of knowingly goes
through all of the issues of
the things that will break a
person's fast as we'll get into
inshallah. Except for
menstruation and postpartum.
The third thing, those are two
things, right? Eating or
drinking or anything that takes
their place or anything that
goes in the way that they go
and we'll mention that next
week. The third thing is making
yourself self-induced vomiting.
If you vomit because you're
sick, it doesn't break your
fast. But if you make yourself
vomit, then it will break your
fast. For and five is
menstruation and postpartum and
number six is intercourse and
again, purposefully and we will
expound upon these next week
inshallah.
[Arabic recitation]